Matt Lauer accused of rape but beat ex
today anchor is fighting back the talk
Sheryl Underwood is here is my guest
co-host and this is a topic that was a
hot topic on your show today yes it was
and most of the comments came from Marie
Sharon and myself there's a lot to say
about this a word of warning to everyone
out there the allegations are disturbing
and had Matt's former colleagues visibly
shaken this morning this is shocking and
appalling you know it's very very very
difficult
I think we're going to just sort of
continue to process this part of this
horrific story and I think I speak for
all of us fear disturbed
in our core yeah this morning savanna
and Hoda were grappling with a horrific
new claim about their former Today Show
co-host in excerpts from Ronan Pharos
new book catch and kill this woman
Brooke nevels alleges that Lauer anally
raped her
while they were in Sochi Russia covering
the 2014 Winter Olympics nevels worked
for anchor Meredith Vieira in excerpts
nevels claims that Lauer invited her to
his hotel room after a night of drinks
and then quote pushed her against the
door and onto the bed adding that it was
non-consensual in the sense that I was
too drunk to consent
nevels also claims the encounter was
excruciating ly painful the former
producer says in the book there were
more sexual encounters when she and
Lauer returned to New York after the me2
movement nevels reportedly told Meredith
about the alleged incident Vieira urged
her to file a formal complaint with HR
which helped lead to Lauer's firing the
former Today Show anchor fired back
today with a three-page response quote I
have never assaulted anyone or forced
anyone to have sex period
he says nevels seemed to know exactly
what she wanted to do Mac does admit
that he quote ended the affair poorly
and simply stopped communicating with
her meanwhile ours divorce from Annette
Roco was finalized last month
they were however spotted together
recently at their daughter's horse show
in the Hamptons the 61 year old also
resurfaced on social media last week in
them lip-syncing and dancing in tick
tock videos with his daughter a source
tells et matt has agreed to pay Annette
about 20 million dollars in the divorce
now NBC News released this statement
quote Matt Lauer's conduct was appalling
horrific and reprehensible as we said at
the time that's why he was fired within
24 hours of us learning of the complaint
[Music]